eine beton ruine in einer
kraterlandschaft die zum symbol des
sieges über nazi deutschland wird
viele sagten ein himmelfahrtskommando
[Musik]
ein wolkenkratzer der auch turm des
todes genannt wird
[Musik]
seit menschen bauen geht es darum wer am
höchsten bauen kann
eine festung auf see mit einer
schrecklichen geschichte
gruselig es gab keinen ausweg das ist
eine gruft
und ein ausgedientes industrie ungetüm
im abgelegenen norden englands
das wirkt wie eine urzeitmonster wie ein
ausgestorbenen dinosaurier
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann würden
die anlagen aufgegeben manche sind heute
lebensgefährlich verseucht doch wer
waren ihre erbauer wie würden sie
errichtet und warum wurden sie wieder
aufgegeben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine langsame in der normandie im westen
frankreichs auf einer 30 meter hohen
klippe steht ein seltsames gebäude
durch den duft sieht man einen großen
betonbau der direkt vorne auf der
landspitze steht
[Musik]
auf dem gebäude ragt eine phallus artige
struktur in den himmel die die ganze
landschaft dominiert
unter der dicken betondecke führen gänge
zu verwaisten räumen
diese räume haben nichts menschliches an
sich es kommt einem so vor als wären sie
von maschinen für maschinen gebaut
wurden
die landschaft um das unheimliche
gebäude ist von kratzern übersät
so weit das auge reicht sieht man diese
merkwürdigen krater es sieht fast aus
wie auf dem mond
an diesem ort ist etwas furchtbares
passiert
doch was hat diese küste so entstellt
für die antwort müssen wir mehr als 70
jahre in der geschichte zurückgehen es
ist d day der tag an dem die alliierten
in frankreich landen um ganz europa von
der knechtschaft der nazis zu befreien
es ist die grösste invasions flotte
aller zeiten mit insgesamt 156 1000
soldaten
england die usa und kanada hatten die
landung auf einer geheimen konferenz in
québec im august 1943 beschlossen
[Musik]
angeführt wird die invasion vom
oberbefehlshaber der alliierten
expedition streitkräfte in europa
us-general wald die eisenhauer
[Musik]
das kommando über die bodentruppen hat
der britische general bernard montgomery
[Musik]
deutschland war klar dass es keinen zwei
fronten krieg gewinnen konnte es war
unmöglich die angriffe der sowjets im
osten abzuwehren und gleichzeitig im
westen zu kämpfen
[Musik]
deswegen hatte hitler befohlen die küste
gegen eine drohende invasion zu
befestigen er ließ den sogenannten
atlantik weil errichten
der touristenführer anthony louis
erklärt was das ist
der atlantik war ein system von
verteidigungsanlagen das schon
nordnorwegen über die französische küste
bis runter zur spanischen küste reichte
insgesamt über 2600 kilometer
doch wenn es eine alliierte invasion
gelbe wo würde sie stattfinden welche
bereiche sollte man besonders befestigen
deutsche oberkommando war uneins wo die
alliierten angreifen würden hitler
glaubte dass sie den kürzesten weg
zwischen dover und calais nehmen doch
andere waren der meinung dass es bessere
und überraschendere ziele für einen
angriff gab
am stärksten ist der atlantik ball an
der normannischen küste weiter befestigt
[Musik]
die wehrmacht hat von hier einen freien
blick über den ärmelkanal und kann auf
einer invasion frühzeitig reagieren etwa
mit ihren gefürchteten küsten batterien
die freie schussbahn auf das meer um die
umliegenden strände haben
dies war einer von zwei verdeckten
deutschen bunkern in denen je eines der
insgesamt 6 155 mm geschütze
untergebracht war
jeder bunker bestand aus
durchschnittlich 660 tonnen beton und 50
tonnen stahl feindlicher beschuss konnte
diesen konstruktionen nur wenig anhaben
die riesigen artilleriegeschütze sind
eine ernste bedrohung für die
invasionstruppen sie sind zwischen utah
beach und omaha beach stationiert zwei
der fünf strände an denen die alliierten
landen sollten
utah beach ist zwölf kilometer weit im
westen und omaha beach acht kilometer im
osten
und diese 155 millimeter geschütze hat
eine reichweite von 19 kilometer
sie hätten ein massaker an den
landungssteg anrichten können die
alliierten mussten sie unschädlich
machen
den auftrag die riesen geschütze zu
zerstören erhält eine eliteeinheit der
us armee die us army rangers
die rangers waren jung körperlich
unglaublich fit und zudem kluge und
motivierte soldaten
sie waren in der lage selbst
schwierigste aufgaben unter widrigsten
umständen zu meistern
mission lautete landen die klippen hoch
und die deutschen stellungen bei plock
ausschalten
doch die klippen ragen fast 30 meter
steil nach oben
und dort warten mehr als 240
wehrmachtssoldaten auf sie die mission
ist extrem riskant
[Musik]
viele sagten ein himmelfahrtskommando
sechster juni 1944 früh am morgen fast
160.000 alliierte soldaten machen sich
auf den weg von england nach frankreich
die day hat begonnen
eine armada von 7.000 schiffen die
größte amphibische in version der
geschichte sticht den see
als die schiffe sich der küste näherten
begannen die alliierten die deutschen
aus der luft und vom meer aus zu
bombardieren und zu beschießen das
geschoss feuer erhellte den morgen
nach plan wollen die rangers vor der
eigentlichen invasion in pontiac lampen
doch es gibt ein problem
glücklicherweise war die gezeigten
strömung an diesem tag sehr stark und
die strömung die von west nach ost ging
ließ tische für abtreiben nach unterhalb
von
corinna spork schließlich erreichen
liegen sie schon 40 minuten hinter dem
zeitplan zurück und das us bomber morgen
der batterien war beendet worden sie
haben das bombardement vom vortag
eingestellt damit die amerikaner landon
konnten ohne in die luft gejagt zu
werden
doch durch die verspätung hatten die
deutschen zeit aus ihren verstecken und
bunkern zu kommen und ihre verteidigungs
positionen einzunehmen
die rangers mussten schwere klitschnasse
seile und strickleitern rom schießen und
dann ihnen hochklettern sie selbst waren
völlig durchnässt
[Musik]
sie wurden dabei permanent
es muss furchtbar gewesen sein
[Musik]
die deutschen waffen stil handgranaten
hinunter das sind schockgranaten die
menschen taub und bewusstlos machen
und die amerikaner kletterten nach oben
unsere teilweise gingen sie nur mit
finger und zehen spitzen an kleinen
felsvorsprüngen
mit einem ranger feld nimmt ein anderer
seinen platz ein wenn sein seil reißt
greift er sich ein anderes einige
benutzten ihre messer als spitzhacken
heute kann man sich das kaum mehr
vorstellen wenn man über die ruhige see
im kanal schaut diese szenerie männer
klettern die nassen klippen hinauf
überall lärm und das unfassbare chaos
des krieges
das war eine der gefährlichsten
missionen im ganzen zweiten weltkrieg
auf der klippe angekommen erwartet sie
ein erbitterter kampf mann gegen mann
als sie sich schließlich bis zu den
bunkern vorgekämpft haben sind sie
geschockt die riesen geschütze sind
nicht da
[Musik]
155 mm kanonen die deutschen
vermeintlich auf sie gerichtet hatten
ist weit und breit nichts zu sehen
da sind nur baumstämmen und schwarz
gestrichene telefonmasten sie fürchten
natürlich dass die ganze mission all die
toten und all die anstrengungen um porto
zu erobern vergebens waren
die rangers sind perplex und fragen sich
warum die geschütze nicht da sind
die alliierten luftschläge im vorfeld
des d day waren so heftig gewesen dass
die deutschen die geschütze in
sicherheit gebracht hatten
schließlich entdecken die rangers sie
auf einem feldweg in der nähe und
zerstören sie
die mission verlief nicht nach plan
angekündigte verstärkungen trafen nicht
ein
die rangers mussten ihre positionen
schließlich kommt die ersehnte
unterstützung
doch von den 225 männern der compagnie
haben nur 90 überlebt
[Musik]
seit die rangers new york ein mann ist
die vom krieg gezeichnete landschaft
nahezu unverändert geblieben heute
erinnert ein monument in form eines
dolches an die männer die einst die
steilküste erklommen haben die weite
dieses orts ist beeindruckend
im grunde genommen ist die geschichte
dahinter ein sehr simples und sehr
typisches narrativ des krieges der kampf
mann gegen mann und die schiere
entschlossenheit die mission
durchzuziehen
[Musik]
im norden englands unweit der stadt
leeds steht ein merkwürdiges gebilde
[Musik]
wenn man durch den morgennebel auf das
ding zu läuft sieht es aus wie eine art
riesige fabrik die auf zwei podesten
steht und an der vorderseite ist dieser
riesige kran
[Musik]
plötzlich sieht man überall metall ein
gigantisches bauwerk was macht das da
das wirkt wie eine art meine zeit
monster wie ausgestorben
ein undurchdringliches gewirr aus
stahlstreben rollen und rostigen rädern
irgendwo im nirgendwo
konrad ein großer langer arm heraus und
dreieckig angeordnete stahlteile und an
den seiten sieht man merkwürdige
gerätschaften man fragt sich wofür diese
seltsame maschine hier mal benutzt wurde
das stählerne ungetüm wurde einst in den
usa gebaut und dann nach nordengland
geschafft
warum wurde es auf diese weite reise
geschickt
[Musik]
und vor allem was hat dieses mad max
gerät mit einer umweltkatastrophe zu tun
die hier in nordengland bis heute
nachwirkt
die geschichte beginnt in der frühen
nachkriegszeit
1945 hat die labour partei überraschend
die wahlen gewonnen und clement attlee
zum premierminister gemacht labour hatte
seinem wlan weitreichende soziale
reformen versprochen die allerdings viel
geld kosten geld das die regierung nach
dem krieg nicht hat in england herrscht
sparpolitik
rationierungen sind auch nach dem krieg
noch an der tagesordnung
1946 ist der winter bitterkeit fabriken
werden geschlossen die eisenbahnen
stellen ihren betrieb ein und die kohle
wird knapp das leid der menschen ist
groß in höchster not kommen die
vereinigten staaten ihrem bündnispartner
zu hilfe
[Musik]
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg war europa
wirtschaftlich am boden und daten die
usa etwas wirklich visionäres sie
erkannten dass die länder hohe
investitionen brauchen um wieder auf die
beine zu kommen also investierten die
usa in europa in straßenbau in brücken
in schienennetze und lieferten auch
viele maschinen
auch dieses stahl monstrum ist teil des
us hilfsplans mal wird der shift übel
bakker genannt er kommt 1953 aus den usa
nach england mit 1200 tonnen ist der
damals der zweitgrößte seiner art
weltweit
er soll englands kohleindustrie wieder
zur alten stärke verhelfen
ost ball ist eine maschine die im
bergbau genutzt wird sie entfernt die
erdschichten über den kohlevorkommen und
legt so die kohleflöze frei
wenn die kohle dichter der oberfläche
liegt ist sie normalerweise mit erde und
gestein bedeckt sachen die man nicht
haben will und um das werk zu schaffen
nimmt man diesen schiff kübel bagger
die maschine die zwar ziemlich
kompliziert aus aber was sie macht ist
eigentlich ziemlich sinnlos vereinfacht
gesagt baggern die schaufeln material
nach oben das dann mit seilen und ketten
abtransportiert wird
pro reli ist ob borns letzter
baggerführer
[Musik]
das sind ziemlich große und
beeindruckende schaufeln
wenn man drin steht sieht man wie groß
die sind die konten locker 40 50 tonnen
abraum aufnehmen
so schwerfällig der abraumbagger auch
aussieht so effektiv ist er wenn er
loslegt in nur 30 sekunden kann er eine
schaufel voll machen und wieder abgeben
für das äquivalent seines eigenen
gewichts braucht er gerade mal eine
halbe stunde
das ist eine sehr effiziente art des
bergbaus denn man kann den abraum
fördern und hinter sich kippen während
man sich weiter verarbeitet man füllt
immer das loch wieder auf dass man beim
kohleabbau hinterlassen hat
um diesen riesen koloss zu bedienen
braucht man einen baggerführer mit viel
fingerspitzengefühl die
füße sind auf den beiden pedalen rechts
und links mit
einem hebel zieht man die schaufel
reihen und mit dem anderen zieht man sie
nach oben bremsen gibt es nicht man kann
nur mit dem gas arbeiten und so
versuchen das ding unter kontrolle zu
halten
die schaufeln sind nicht ungefährlich
vor allem wenn sie voll sind
[Musik]
diese hebel losgelassen solange ich auf
dem bagger war diese maschine verlangt
volle konzentration
[Musik]
das problem mit diesen riesigen
maschinen ist das immer wenn die kohle
in der reichweite ihres auslegers
abgebaut worden war sie an einen anderen
ort bewegt werden musste alle paar
stunden oder tage musste man mit dem
ding umziehen
der bagger hat diese dinger die aussehen
wie füße und auf denen bewegt er sich
fort
mit diesen plattfüßen kann sich das
ganze gerät anheben und sich dann zurück
schieben ein bisschen wie wenn man auf
dem rücken liegt und sich dann rückwärts
nach hinten schiebt
mit einer schnecken geschwindigkeit von
300 metern pro stunde bewegt sich der
koloss mit jedem schritt zwei meter
rückwärts
doch der baggerführer sieht nicht was
hinter ihnen passiert
wir mussten in den außenspiegel gucken
um den kran ein weiser zu sehen
und wir haben uns so weit wie es geht
aus dem fenster gelehnt um zu gucken ob
wir fahren konnten oder ob etwas im weg
war
[Musik]
das ding ist anders als alles was man
kennt das ist wie star wars und fand der
wird auf bergbau mission und trotzdem
ist die maschine überaus elegant
[Musik]
sie steht mit ihren kurzen beinen auf
und läuft durch die gegend eine wirklich
geniale art des tagebaus
1988 ist der bagger im nordenglischen
zehn tagen im einsatz
[Musik]
senden ist damals der größte tagebau in
ganz york mit einem abbau volumen von 6
millionen tonnen in zehn jahren
doch dann kommt es zur katastrophe
ein ganzer landstrich wird geflutet sind
eben hat plötzlich einen see
das abbaugebiet war sehr dicht an einem
fluss wahrscheinlich zu dicht sie bauten
kohle in einem feuchten tiefen und
gebiet ab und natürlich entstand dabei
eine riesige grube
zwar ist das flussufer mit spundwänden
gesichert doch das reicht nicht aus
während des kohleabbaus wasser aus einem
riss im kohleflöz und zusätzlich drang
wasser aus einem fluss ein den sie
eigentlich umgeleitet hatten
[Musik]
innerhalb weniger stunden bricht die
spundwand zusammen
[Musik]
es war wie in den niagarafällen all das
ganze wasser und die gischt das war eine
totale katastrophe und jeder wusste es
und zwar sofort klar dass unsere jobs
futsch war
mehr als 17 milliarden liter fluten den
tagebau
der künstliche see war mehr als
anderthalb kilometer breit und 60 meter
tief er war so groß dass es tage dauerte
bis alles geflutet war
und wir wussten dass die maschinen erst
mal still stehen würden
osborne überlebt das desaster doch es
dauert zehn jahre ehe er die arbeit
wieder aufnehmen kann
die überschwemmungen schließlich zurück
ging und man mit dem abbau weitermachen
konnte war die technologie inzwischen
vorangeschritten scherf kübel bagger
wurden überflüssig und durch andere
systeme ersetzt
im januar 1990 gerät zum letzten mal
seine schaufeln in die nordenglische
erde
seitdem steht der bagger einer der
letzten seiner art stille
[Musik]
ich bin ein großer fan davon unser
technologisches erbe zu bewahren
vor allem wenn es um diese riesigen
maschinen gilt denn man vergisst so
schnell wie viel harte arbeit
erfindergeist und welche technik man
brauchte um unsere moderne welt zu
erschaffen
[Musik]
am eingang zur manila bucht vor der
philippinischen hauptinsel luzon fragt
ein merkwürdiges bauwerk aus dem meer
das auf den ersten blick an ein
kriegsschiff erinnert
ein militärisches meeresungeheuer aus
beton total er
das riesige bauwerk hat viele schlitze
und öffnungen so kann man sehen wie
unglaublich dick die mauern sind
und man sieht den ganzen stahl
was macht dieses archaische kriegsschiff
das aussieht als wäre es aus dem fels
herausgeschlagen am eingang der manila
bucht
auch der blick ins innere gibt wenig
aufschluss über den zweck dieses
bauwerks drinnen ist nur bremsender
beton und rostiger stahl
die verkohlten wände lassen erahnen dass
sich hier etwas schreckliches abgespielt
haben muss
man sieht dass die wände hier schon
zusammenbrechen und da ist ein loch im
boden
das meerwasser dringt langsam ein
überall liegt verbogenes metall unschuld
was immer hier passiert ist wer hier
drin war konnte das kaum überleben
[Musik]
welche funktion hatte diese archaische
beton monolith und was hat er mit einem
der grausamsten ereignisse des zweiten
weltkriegs zu tun
[Musik]
um diese fragen zu beantworten müssen
wir bis zum anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts zurückgehen die usa sind
dabei zu einer großmacht aufzusteigen
1898 hatten sie in spanisch
amerikanischen krieg gewonnen und sich
anschließend die philippinen bis dahin
eine spanische kolonie einverleibt wegen
ihrer strategisch wichtigen lage wollen
die vereinigten staaten die philippinen
um jeden preis halten und dieses beton
kriegsschiff soll dabei eine wichtige
rolle spielen
heimatforscher erwarte labrador kennt
die ganze geschichte
die us-aktien 198 die philippinen
eroberten fuhren sie einfach rein und
versenkten die spanische flotte damit
ihnen nicht das gleiche passiert wie den
spanien damals brauchten sie ein
effektives verteidigungssystem
ein wesentlicher bestandteil dieses
systems ist dass beton schlachtschiff
auf dem kleinen eiland 11 reilly
am eingang der manila bucht sind mehrere
versprengte inseln einige davon wie
korridor sind größer andere wie 11 reile
ziemlich klein
doch ihre lage am eingang zur bucht ist
geradezu perfekt für die damals neu
entwickelte küstenartillerie
die ursprünglichen pläne sehen vor jede
der fünf inseln zu festungen auszubauen
die anlage auf 11 reihe auch fort drum
genannt ist die mächtigste doch wie ist
sie gebaut worden
die insel wurde eingeebnet und bis zum
grund abgetragen und darauf bauten sie
dann diesen massiven betonklotz mit
diesen beiden dingen die aussehen wie
geschütztürme und die schiffe versenken
sollten
das hier sind die riesigen 35cm
geschütze
man kann sich gut vorstellen was für
einen durchmesser diese granaten hatten
von denen jede eine tonne schwer ba rund
acht kilometer weit flog die deckten die
komplette bucht ab
ford dran ist gewaltig es gibt
suchscheinwerfer
flugabwehrgeschütze und eine feuerleiter
turm hinter dem bis zu zwölf meter
dickem stahlbeton wandel ist auf drei
ebenen platz für material und mehr als
200 soldaten
[Musik]
dies hier sind die stadtwerke zwei und
drei hier waren die aufenthaltsräume und
das casino
und anstatt aktiver waren die
generatoren und wasser in diesen gängen
werden vorräte munition und weitere
ausrüstung gelagert um notfalls lange
hier ausharren zu können doch vor wir
wollen sich die usa schützen und warum
ist das vor heute eine ruine
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
hatten viele in den usa angst vor einem
angriff der japaner
die länder asiens waren damals nach
meinung einiger eine bedrohung für die
westliche welt
es war nur eine frage der zeit bis es
knallen würde
und es knallt heftig an achten dezember
1941 greifen die japaner pearl harbor
gleichzeitig marschieren sie auf den
philippinen ein sie wollen ein gros
japanisches reich im pazifik errichten
die lage der philippinen ist dafür
strategisch wichtig wer die philippinen
beherrscht beherrscht den pazifik raum
[Musik]
von hier aus gibt es eine direkte route
nach australien und ozeanien
die philippinen liegen in der mitte
zwischen nord und süd pazifik
und es gibt noch einen weiteren grund
für den angriff die usa kontrollieren
die philippinen und sie sind der größte
widersacher der japaner im pazifik
entsprechend heftig sind die gefechte um
den inselstaat
anfang 1942 greifen die japaner fort
drum an sowohl aus der luft als auch mit
artillerie doch von tram steht wie ein
fels in der brandung
[Musik]
vorrang spielt seit beginn des kriegs
eine wichtige rolle in den monaten bis
zum fünften mal haben die japaner vor
tram immer wieder aus der luft und mit
geschützen angegriffen
dem voran müssen einem die
bombenangriffe heftig vorgekommen sein
aber vielleicht hat man sich trotzdem
relativ sicher gefühlt denn die mauern
waren so dick dass einem eigentlich
wenig passieren konnte
[Musik]
obwohl die garnison belagert wird können
die us-truppen den japanischen invasoren
empfindliche verluste zufügen und die
geschütze er fort dranhalten allen
angriffen stand
die geschütztürme sind aus panzerstahl
aus dem gleichen material aus dem
kriegsschiffe gebaut werden es sind ja
auch chefs geschützt und das dach ist
aus stahl beton so dass keine
japanischen granaten durchgekommen sind
doch am 6 mai 1942 verlieren die usa die
schlacht um die philippinen die soldaten
in fort drum müssen sich ergeben
hat den bombenhagel der japaner ohne
verluste überstanden es gab keinen
einzigen toten
das ding war so stabil dass die japaner
trotz monatelangem heftigem
artilleriebeschuss von allen seiten
keinen nennenswerten schaden angerichtet
haben
[Musik]
die usa haben die schlacht verloren aber
der krieg geht weiter
drei jahre lang bleibt ford gramm unter
japanischer kontrolle bis zum 13 april
1945 als 2 us landungsboote sich die
festungs insel zurückholen
juni ändern diese waffenstarrende
festung
und pumpen ein gemisch aus diesel und
benzin ins innere
und dann feuern sie leuchtspurmunition
hinein
die japaner im innern wollten sich nicht
ergeben obwohl ihnen klar gewesen sein
musste was passieren würde
diskussion war so heftig dass alle der
rund 1000 kilo schwere lücken fast 100
meter weit durch die luft flog
die verkohlten betonwände im inneren von
ford ram sind stumme zeugen des infernos
bei dem alle japaner getötet worden
wir betreten jetzt das dritte
untergeschoss als
[Musik]
die amerikaner oben benzin in die luken
gossen sammelte sich das meiste hier
unten und darum sind die meisten
japanischen leichen 60 der insgesamt 68
hier unten gefunden worden
[Musik]
sie hatten keine chance hier
rauszukommen das ist eine gruft tun
als eine gruselige vorstellung dass hier
60 menschen verbrannten und keine chance
hatten rauszukommen erst vier tage
später konnten die amerikaner ryan weil
die hitze einfach unerträglich waren
seitdem ist von verlassen
wie ein mahnmal des krieges vor der
philippinischen küste
plünderer haben alles verwertbare aus
der ruine herausgeholt
heute wissen nur noch wenige von der
existenz dieser festungs insel und ihrer
bedeutenden rolle in der geschichte des
pazifik raums
die verteidigung von ford traum ist von
der militärgeschichte fast vergessen
worden doch diese geschichte sollte
erzählt werden
[Musik]
im herzen russlands liegt die katharinen
burg die viertgrößte stadt des landes
und in ihrem zentrum steht ein
bemerkenswertes monument
da ist dieser große graue beton turm der
die stadt überragt und er wegen seiner
enormen höhe nicht zu übersehen ist
das komische daran er ist unglaublich
dünn und hoch kaum zu glauben dass
dieses zierliche bauwerk nicht umkippt
220 meter ertrag die beton nadel in den
himmel
[Musik]
hohe türme machen immer eindruck auf uns
menschen
seitdem wir sachen bauen geht es immer
auch darum wer am höchsten baut heißt
es drängt sich der gedanke auf dass es
um symbole geht
die mauern sind mit graffiti voll
geschmiert der beton bröckelt und ein
klaffendes schwarzes loch zeugt von
einem schrecklichen ereignis die
einheimischen mögen den turm nicht
besonders
[Musik]
für viele in der stadt hat der
verlassene turm etwas unheimliches
es ist ein geister turm
aber warum mögen die menschen den
gigantischen turm nicht warum denn die
einheimischen ihn den turm des todes
die antworten auf diese fragen haben
ihren ursprung in der zeit des kalten
krieges
in der sowjetunion ging es maßgeblich
darum in sachen wissenschaft und technik
die nase vorn zu haben man wollte
beweisen dass das sozialistische system
die besseren wissenschaftler und
ingenieure hervorbrachte
während des kalten krieges investieren
sowohl kommunistische als auch
kapitalistischen regierungen riesige
summen in forschung und technik
[Musik]
die wichtigsten bereiche sind die
raumfahrt und die atomwaffen forschung
aber auch grundlagenforschung
landwirtschaft bio und
computertechnologie erhalten großzügige
staatliche zuwendungen
stets geht es darum wer der größte beste
oder schnellste ist
das gilt auch für die architektur und
die frage wer am höchsten bauen kann
anfang der 80er jahre hat der westen
hier klar die nase vorn doch die
sowjetunion stellt sich den wettbewerb
und baut unter anderem das den
fernsehturm von jekaterinenburg
das fernsehen ist seinerzeit immerhin
das propagandamedium um die botschaft
von der überlegenheit des sozialismus in
die welt zu tragen
das fernsehen ist ein sehr effektives
kommunikationsmittel wer die drei oder
vier verfügbaren kanäle im land
kontrolliert bestimmt über was die leute
reden
mit 365 metern höhe soll er einer der
höchsten fernsehtürme werden
er wurde aus zwei teilen zusammengesetzt
einer etwa 220 meter langen
stahlbetonrohre und einer über 140 meter
langen antenne aus metall
in das neue wahrzeichen der stadt sollen
fernsehstudios einziehen oben soll es
ein drehbares restaurant geben
[Applaus]
doch der bau erweist sich als ziemlich
schwierig
[Musik]
zunächst wurde ein entsprechendes gerüst
um den eigentlichen turm herum gebaut
dann musste man eine spezielle gussform
aus holz bauen in die der beton
eingegossen wurde
das wurde alles in abschnitten gemacht
weil der turm so enorm groß ist
nicht zuletzt sind die bauarbeiten für
die beteiligten arbeiter
lebensgefährlich
[Musik]
ein betonring wurde gegossen und dann
der nächste drauf gegossen so ging es
stück für stück höher
jeder dieser ringe war etwa zwei bis
zweieinhalb meter hoch wenn ein ring
getrocknet war wurde der nächste drauf
gegossen und so gossen siering
aufbringen doch je höher sie kamen desto
schwieriger wurde es den flüssigen beton
in diese enorme höhe zu pumpen
[Musik]
aber der turm wächst und wächst trotz
bitterer kälte und materialengpässen
der turm sollte nicht nur propaganda
verbreiten er selbst war eine form von
propaganda ein wahrzeichen für die
überlegenheit des sowjetsystems
doch angesichts all der mühen und kosten
was hat letztendlich dazu geführt dass
der turm nie fertiggestellt wurde ein
unfall oder
die perestroika anfang der 90er jahre
die der anfang vom ende der sowjetunion
war haben terroristen einen anschlag
verübt
weg und ist weit banaler
nach acht jahren bauzeit waren gerade
einmal zwei drittel fertig das geld
wurde knapp und die öffentlichkeit war
nicht länger willens so ein projekt zu
unterstützen
was ein symbol sowjetischer
überlegenheit werden sollte wird ein
mahnmal des scheiterns
doch eines ist noch offen wieso heißt
der gigantische beton farbton des todes
nach dem abbruch der arbeiten wird die
bauruine sich selbst überlassen niemand
interessiert sich mehr für sie außer
einer gruppe jugendlicher die den ton
für sich entdeckt
[Musik]
rom wurde zu einer art
abenteuerspielplatz für die jugendlichen
viele sind hinaufgeklettert und oben war
ständig party irgendwann versuchten
einige verrückte mit verbundenen augen
nach oben zu klettern worden
es kam zu unfällen und ein junger mann
starb andere benutzten den toom um sich
auf möglichst spektakuläre art
umzubringen
nach drei todesfällen machen die
behörden den turm zu hier sollen niemand
mehr umlegen können
[Musik]
am 24 märz 2018 wird das traurige
wahrzeichen jekaterinenburg es dann
schließlich gesprengt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute ist von dem turm der einst die
skyline der stadt dominierte nichts mehr
zu sehen
an seiner stelle wird eine eisbahn
gebaut
ich kann verstehen dass der turm ein
wahrzeichen war auch dass einige auch
stolz waren
andererseits kann niemand ernsthaft ein
symbol des scheiterns in seiner stadt
haben wollen das so unübersehbar ist
[Applaus]
er wurde nie genutzt und nie
fertiggestellt und wenn man ihn dann
abreißt um platz für neue kulturelle
projekte zu schaffen dann ist das doch
ein schritt nach vorn ich glaube man
muss mit der zeit gehen und die bauten
den bedürfnissen einer stadt anpassen
[Musik]
einst waren sie symbole der macht und
des fortschritts heute sind sie
verlassen in diesen verfallenen bauten
sind die echos der geschichte hörbar sie
könnten vom krieg und terror von
erfindergeist und
menschlichen streben
[Musik]